Transcription: Marie-Aude Piquet
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Tout a commencé un beau dimanche,
un beau matin.
C'était en 1996.
J’avais 16 ans.
C’était à une gare routière.
Les Stéphanois connaissent
cette gare routière,
c’était la place Chavanel.
Les cars rouges se garaient là.
Dans ce décor idyllique,
entre deux pots d’échappement,
j’ai vu des garçons faire du skate.
Ils sautaient sur les trottoirs,
ils glissaient sur les quais,
ils slalomaient entre les bus,
et j’ai trouvé ça juste génial.
J’ai pensé : « Ça a l’air cool,
j’ai trop envie d’en faire. »
La semaine d’après,
j’ai acheté une planche.
Une copine m’a accompagnée
parce que j’avais peur d’y aller seule.
Je ne sais pas si ça se voit,
mais je suis assez timide et réservée.
Aujourd’hui pour moi,
c’est compliqué de m’adresser à vous.
Je suis allée skater sur cette place.
À l’époque, les garçons y allaient,
tout le monde se rassemblait.
Et quand j’arrivais sur la place,
les garçons partaient,
ils allaient skater ailleurs.
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe ?
Pourquoi ils s’en vont quand j’arrive ?
Je me suis rendu compte
qu’il n’y avait pas de femmes
dans ce sport
et que certains n’étaient pas très enclins
à en voir arriver sur leurs platebandes.
Je me suis alors dit
« je vais aller faire du skate
à un moment où ces garçons
ne sont pas sur la place. »
J’y suis allée le samedi matin, seule,
parce que je ne voulais pas être jugée
ou moquée pour ce que je faisais.
Plus j’en faisais,
plus je trouvais ça passionnant.
Plus je m’éclatais à rouler partout,
plus je comprenais l’exigence de ce sport.
Par exemple, justement,
pour monter un trottoir de 30 cm,
il m’a fallu plus de six mois.
Six mois de travail acharné
pour monter un trottoir.
Donc le skate n’est pas un sport facile,
on tombe beaucoup.
C’est peut-être pour ça aussi
qu’il n’y avait peu de femmes.
On se blesse énormément aussi.
Les passants, en général,
ne sont pas très contents de nous voir.
J’ai reçu des coups de sac dans le ventre
une bonne cinquantaine de fois.
La police aussi nous coursait
parce qu’on n’avait pas le droit
de faire de skate
dans la rue ou sur ces places.
Il fallait courir assez vite
pour ne pas finir au poste.
La plupart de mes journées,
je les passais dans la rue,
et j’ai subi pas mal d’agressions.
Effectivement,
quand on est dehors comme ça,
on est un peu confronté
à la misère du monde.
Petit à petit, j’ai croisé
des skaters un peu plus sympas,
souvent un petit peu plus vieux que moi,
qui étaient contents
de voir des filles faire du skate.
Ils m’ont dit de venir skater avec eux.
J’ai appris des figures avec eux,
à faire partie d’une communauté,
et j’ai progressé.
À partir de là, j’ai eu envie
de faire des compétitions.
Dans le coin,
juste des compétitions locales,
pour rigoler, pour être avec mes potes,
pour changer de lieu,
parce qu’il n’y avait pas de skatepark,
et je n’avais que cette place ou la rue.
Je voulais aussi aller voir
dans les autres skateparks
si d’autres filles pratiquaient.
Parce que c’était la question :
où sont-elles ?
À votre avis, dans ces compétitions,
y avait-il beaucoup de filles ?
Malheureusement non.
Il y en avait très peu, voire pas du tout.
Pour moi, ce n’était pas normal,
quelque chose clochait.
J’ai eu l’idée d’écrire une lettre
au seul magazine français qui existait,
qui s’appelait Tricks.
Je leur ai écrit en me présentant
et en demandant :
« Pourquoi les filles ne skatent pas ? »
J’avais besoin qu’on me réponde
et qu’on me dise pourquoi.
J’invitais aussi les gens à m’écrire
pour donner leur avis,
pour peut-être se rencontrer un jour
et faire du skate ensemble.
Ça, c’est la lettre qui a été publiée.
J’étais très contente
d’être dans le magazine.
C’est sans doute la première fois
que quelqu’un de St-Étienne était publié
et avait une réponse.
J’ai reçu une cinquantaine de lettres
de toute la France
et même de Guadeloupe.
Quelques filles m’ont écrit,
qu’elles étaient
dans le même état d’esprit que moi
et ne comprenaient pas
pourquoi elles étaient rejetées.
Beaucoup de garçons ont écrit
et étaient contents d’en voir,
et voulaient que je continue
et que j’aille plus loin.
Ça m’a vraiment boostée.
Je me suis rendu compte
que c’était très difficile
de s’imposer dans ce sport.
Pas qu’à St-Etienne,
mais dans toute la France.
Avec ce constat,
je me dis :  « tu dois voyager plus,
faire plus de compétition,
il faut que tu y ailles,
tu as le droit d’être là,
les filles ont le droit d’être là.
Si les filles te voient
faire du skate en compétitions,
ça briserait sans doute
des barrières mentales. »
Oui, on peut faire de la compétition,
on peut faire du skate
et on peut même gagner des compétitions.
J’en ai gagné quelques unes.
J’étais un peu la seule des fois,
je me battais contre moi même.
Mais, c’est pas très grave, hein !
Et ça explique aussi pourquoi
j’ai des chaussures de cette taille
et pourquoi j’ai ce T-shirt,
parce qu’en fait je gagnais
des lots pour garçons.
Voilà, j’ai rempli mon armoire de tout ça.
Une autre chose m’a choquée
dans ces lots.
Sur les championnats de France,
les garçons gagnaient de l’argent,
ils partaient avec un chèque.
Et nous les filles, on repartait
avec des accessoires pourris.
C’était bof,
mais ça a changé maintenant.
Maintenant il y a une parité
dans les prize money.
À force de compétitions,
j’ai croisé de plus en plus de filles,
et on a été de plus en plus nombreuses.
Là, à mes premiers championnats de France,
à Chelles, en région parisienne,
il y avait beaucoup de débutantes.
L’idée était de faire la compétition
quel que soit notre niveau.
On voulait juste montrer
qu’on était là, qu’on existait.
Petit à petit, on a été
de plus en plus nombreuses
et à avoir un bon niveau.
En général, sur les compétitions,
on était à peu près cinq ou six.
Ensuite, j’ai fait
des compétitions européennes.
Je suis allée à Munich
aux championnats d’Europe.
Là, vraiment,
j’ai eu une révélation car j’ai vu
des filles bien plus fortes que moi,
qui skataient partout,
il y en avait plein.
Ça m’a donné l’espoir, la motivation
pour aller toujours plus loin.
J’étais contente, j’avais fini sixième
à cette compétition,
je n’étais pas si ridicule que ça,
la petite Française au milieu.
L’année d’après, j’étais arrivée deuxième
aux championnats d’Europe,
donc c’était plutôt cool !
Grâce à tout ça,
mes voyages, mes compétitions,
des marques, puis des magazines
se sont intéressés à ce que je faisais.
Des magazines sont venus m’interviewer,
Et c’était très rare à l’époque
de voir une femme dans ces magazines.
Par exemple, là,
dans le magazine Ride On, en 1999.
J’ai eu une interview.
Je devais monter à Paris
faire la photo avec un professionnel,
sur un lieu de skate, à Bercy.
Beaucoup d’Américains
venaient y faire des photos.
J’avais vraiment une grosse pression,
j’étais avec un photographe professionnel,
là où tous les skateurs
faisaient leurs photos,
il fallait que j’assure un peu.
C’était une revanche aussi,
sur la place Chavanelle,
parce qu’aucun skateur n’avait encore
été publié en photo dans un magazine.
C’était une victoire quand même.
Après, je suis allée un peu à Paris,
j’ai joué dans des publicités,
j’ai fait des doublages
dans certains films,
et j’ai participé
à des plateaux télé, des jeux télé.
Certaines marques
sponsorisaient des skateurs
en fonction des valeurs
qu’ils représentaient,
de leur implication dans le skate,
de leur représentation dans le milieu.
Du coup, on me donnait des vêtements,
des chaussures, des planches.
J’ai même été sponsorisée
par une marque de sous-vêtements.
Partager les mêmes valeurs
et skater avec ces marques
nous permettait de montrer
un attachement à ces valeurs.
Ça permettait aux autres skateurs,
pas de nous prendre pour modèle,
je n’aime pas trop ce mot,
mais ils pouvaient se dire :
« Quelqu’un l’a fait, pourquoi pas moi ? »
Grâce à ces marques,
on partait en tournée,
avec toute l’équipe, toute la team.
Je me retrouvais qu’avec des garçons,
j’étais souvent la seule femme.
Par exemple, je suis allée en Tunisie.
On skatait dans la rue,
on était accueilli
par des milliers de personnes,
on faisait des démonstrations
sur les places,
Pour la petite histoire,
sur cette photo,
on s’est rendus sur le lieu en calèche.
On avait une fanfare derrière nous
et des majorettes, c’était dingue.
On est arrivé sur cette place
avec des gens partout qui criaient
et on devait skater.
Enfin, c’est des souvenirs énormes.
Ensuite, j’ai rencontré pas mal de filles
qui partageaient mes valeurs.
Et j’ai eu envie de monter avec elles
une sorte de communauté sur internet.
C'était en 2004.
Il n’y avait pas encore
de réseaux sociaux.
Notre seul moyen de communication,
c’était le téléphone, et un peu internet.
En France, il n’y avait pas
de site dédié aux filles.
On l’a donc créé.
On l’a appelé Poseuz Crew
Une poseuse, ou un poseur,
en langue skateurs,
c’est quelqu’un qui a une planche,
qui est habillé en skateur,
et qui ne pratique pas
parce que c’est bien trop dur, hein !
Mais comme c’est un sport cool,
ils achètent une planche.
Notre nom, c’était un peu un pied de nez.
On s’appelait donc Poseuz Crew,
on partageait des news
sur le skate féminin,
on partageait des vidéos ;
à chaque compétition,
on faisait une vidéo
et on la postait sur sur le site.
On avait surtout un forum d’échange
avec autant d’hommes que de femmes,
où tout le monde était bienveillant.
Beaucoup de filles ont réussi,
grâce à ce forum,
à discuter, à échanger.
Tout le monde parlait de son ressenti,
de ses peurs, de ses victoires,
au jour le jour, dans sa ville,
dans sa scène skate.
C’était une vraie belle réussite,
ce site internet,
parce qu’il a permis
de faire émerger des talents.
Je pense que vous avez compris que
le skate n’est pas qu’une planche en bois.
Beaucoup d’autres choses gravitent autour.
Il y a aussi de l’art,
de la musique, des vidéos.
J’ai écouté, j’ai regardé
des vidéos de skate,
il y a avait du punk rock
parce que c’est la musique qui allait bien
avec le style du skate,
le truc un peu rentre dedans,
le béton, le goudron...
Je suis allée voir des concerts
à Saint-Étienne.
À cette époque, il y avait
une scène bien développée.
J’arrive au concert
et je fais le même constat,
dans le public,
pas beaucoup de femmes,
et sur scène, encore moins.
Un seul groupe de filles
jouait à l’époque.
J’ai pensé : « c’est trop bien, le punk!
Pourquoi les filles n’en font pas ? »
À votre avis, j’ai fait quoi ?
J’ai fait du punk!
J’ai acheté une guitare,
appris un accord, un seul,
puis j’ai écrit des chansons
et créé un groupe.
C’était en 1998.
Je suis montée sur scène,
Premier concert au Sporting, franchement,
je ne savais pas du tout jouer !
Mais on était entre potes,
on rigolait, on jouait,
on faisait du bruit, on s’amusait,
en prenant du plaisir,
ça se résumait à ça finalement.
La vie pour moi, c’est vraiment ça,
juste faire ce qu’on a envie.
Le temps est passé, j’ai continué
à faire du skate, des concerts.
Et un beau matin en 2014,
c’est toujours un beau matin, d’ailleurs,
J'ai entendu que le skate allait
devenir un sport olympique.
Sur le coup, j’ai trouvé ça dommage,
le skate, ça se pratique dans la rue,
c’est même pas un sport,
c’est une culture.
Pourquoi l’intégrer aux JO?
En poussant la réflexion un peu plus loin,
ça devient évident.
Il faut que le skate aille
aux JO, pourquoi?
Parce que les femmes vont se retrouver
sur un pied d’égalité avec les hommes.
Une équipe de femmes va aller aux JO.
Elles vont intégrer une équipe de France,
être suivies et devenir
des athlètes de haut niveau.
C’était une superbe opportunité pour elles
de faire quelque chose de leur vie.
J’étais super contente!
Au même moment, la Fédération Française
de roller et skate board
m’a appelée pour me demander
de m’occuper du collectif filles.
C’était un peu les prémices
de l’équipe de France.
Il fallait trouver 6 à 7 skateuses
de bon niveau,
organiser une tournée,
faire des vidéos, des photos,
et repérer si une ou deux d’entre elles
seraient intéressées pour aller aux JO,
ou pour faire une carrière.
J’ai dit oui tout de suite et ai organisé
ce collectif filles chez moi à Beauzac.
Elles sont venues à la maison,
on dormait dans mon grenier,
à la bonne franquette.
Pas de pression, juste,
on va skater, on fait des photos,
et on verra.
Les filles étaient donc à la maison.
Ce qui est drôle,
c’est que j’habite à la campagne,
j’ai un jardin et un potager,
comme tout le monde à la campagne,
j’ai un poulailler
et aussi une rampe de skate
là où on est assises.
Je me suis occupée du collectif filles
jusqu’en 2017,
l’année où l’équipe de France a vu le jour
et où les filles ont intégré l’équipe.
Mon engagement dans le skate reste intact.
J’ai vraiment envie de mettre
mon expérience au service des autres.
J’ai passé mon diplôme de juge national,
donc je juge les compétitions nationales,
et je suis élue au conseil
d’administration de la fédération.
Le fait d’être à ce poste,
même si ce n’est pas vraiment un poste,
être élue et représenter mon sport
et ma vision du sport,
je trouve ça très important.
Et avoir cette responsabilité
en tant que femme,
c’est un signe fort par rapport
au parcours qui m’a amenée jusque-là.
Je vais conclure sur cette idée:
j’aime dire que ma vie a commencé
quand j’ai eu 16,
quand j’ai découvert
cette planche à roulettes toute simple
quand j’ai découvert un nouveau monde
que j’ai pu exploré très loin.
Je suis assez heureuse
et fière de mon évolution,
d’avoir franchi les barrières
mises sur ma route.
Le leitmotiv qui m’a suivie toute ma vie,
sur tout ce que j’entreprends finalement,
Il se résume en quelques mots :
Découvrir.
Observer.
Oser.
S’accrocher.
Beaucoup s’accrocher.
Réussir...
ou pas.
Et recommencer.
Finalement, c’est un peu
l’histoire d’une figure de skate.
Merci.